[Music]
g is for greenwash they are basically
painting a story
like they're doing what needs to be done
for the climate and ecological emergency
there'll be a big greenwashing effort in
glasgow that needs to be called out and
recognized
[Music]
there's two problems two things i'll
focus on here one of them is is claims
of being carbon neutral so today we
often see that high emitting companies
claim that their businesses or perhaps
their products are already carbon
neutral and that we see as a real red
flag
because what it is unfortunately it's in
fictional accounting for carbon what
companies call carbon offsetting but the
problem that we have is that carbon
offsets don't actually cancel out the
emissions from fossil fuels
and they can't critically
replace what we need to do which is to
drastically reduce burning coal oil and
gas companies can't use carbon offsets
to reassure consumers that they're
actually acting on climate change but
they nevertheless often just label it
carbon neutral
there are more and more companies
putting out promises of reaching net
zero by 2050.
we think the easiest way to tell if that
is credible is just to look to see if
it's clearly backed up by immediate
action
the science here is clear it says we
need to reduce emissions by at least
half by 2030 that's in the next nine
years so the question we'd ask is why
isn't a company with a net zero target
talking about what percentage of its
overall emissions it's reducing in the
next three years in the next five years
in that sort of time frame
[Applause]
companies particularly oil and gas
companies have
some emissions that come from their
their operations but the vast vast
majority of their emissions come from
their products
and so when they're not being completely
clear about the amount of emissions that
they're going to cut from their overall
emissions and the including those of
their products then you get a real risk
of green washing so we see that green
washing is creeping well outside the oil
and gas industry so this is the key
transition areas things like energy
things like cars planes home heating
meat and also of course the finance
sector that supports them
although we see that some environmental
marketing claims are legitimate many do
give an impression which isn't backed up
by action we can't use any more empty
promises of climate action or reassuring
messages we need real action on real
emissions to reduce them in line with
paris agreement goals
[Music]